topol so I've been thinking about it and
the fact that you personally know the
guy in charge of North Korea's cyber
warfare program seemed what relevant to
our interests I was going to say
treasonous but sure let's go with
relevant who is he uh Charles Watson AKA
chubby chucky AKA chucky chubbers AKA
chubby mccarroll Chomper AKA mid chubby
nights chuck aka the man with a thousand
nicknames regarding his weight you
remember all those propaganda photos of
Kim jong-il looking at cucumbers and
radishes and surrounded by North
Korean officials mm-hmm there's always
that one goofy looking white guy kind of
chubby that's Chucky how did a waspy
Yale graduate end up working for the
North Koreans they came to the job fair
nice brochure very glossy lots of horses
on it did you ever bother to tell
Rollins any of this no but I had a good
reason chubby Chucky's a double agent
huh hardly my understanding is he loves
North Korea no on our first night
freshman year chubby Chucky and I shared
a bottle of Pimm's and made an oath to
never betray each other no matter what
it's the most important oath I've ever
made winters because it's the only one
that involved blood lots of blood your
pal probably had deputy chief Rollins
killed and I cheated on my chemistry
midterm and guess what Chevy Chucky said
nothing he's trying to bring down our
country with this virus well now call me
old-fashioned but some things are more
important than the well-being of 300
million innocent civilians besides what
Americans really want to live in a world
where members of the elite are held to
the same standards that they are I doubt
that very much I'm your supervisor I am
commanding you to contact this chubby
Chucky I have to yes or I'll
tell the Alumni Association about that
chemistry midterm oh you would not dare
I'm typing the email now do as I say or
I'll hit Send I was wrong about you Ms
winters didn't realize you had it in you
to take the kill shot on an old man well
I do I'm a cold-blooded hit send on an
email
fine but we need a secure communication
strategy for contacting Chucky we can't
just put a coded message in the cover of
Us Weekly like we're telling OPEC where
to set the price of oil he needs to know
it's me I'm the only one he'll trust
that means we're gonna have to do this
old-school what is old school and tail
it means we need six hundred thousand
dollars cash two identical briefcases a
fee Hulk a cipher machine hot air
balloon Cadbury cream eggs have a bald
eagle and a fake mustache if i get you
all that stuff how soon can you reach
chubby Chucky definitely within the next
five years five years we need this
mission activated by thursday next
Thursday this Thursday oh well I know
this is going to seriously inconvenience
my Thursday bridge partner which half of
the bald eagle do you need